- So Sophia and Sofia's
characters are friends who are set
up to be enemies.
How do you think the dynamic
of that kind of plays out
in real world as well?
'Cause I felt like,
and maybe it's just in the musician world
I don't know if it's the
same in the acting world
but they always try and pit
females against each other.
They do in the music world at least.
- I think in the world at large.
And I thought that was
kind of interesting.
- It's funny, yesterday
we were doing an interview
and somebody said,
"You guys have such
great chemistry up there,
did it feel competitive?"
And we were like, What?
Like no, It felt so inspiring,
I think was the word you used.
Like, which was so great.
It was, we kept upping
the ante for each other
and encouraging each other to play
and find new ways to do the scene.
It didn't feel competitive at all.
- There's just been so little
opportunity for us, right?
And so the little that did come around,
instead of acknowledging that,
there was a need for more opportunity,
they made it about women
not supporting each other.
- [Kerry] Right.
- And I think it was the easy way out
because I have never been more supported
than by the women in my life,
- Mm.
- inspired by the women of my life,
been brave because of
the women in my life.
So we just need more opportunity.
We need-
- [Kelly] That's what I-
- I love being in this film because-
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Just give me a part of something that
can create opportunity for
like, these two young ladies.
To see them in this film,
makes my old dead heart feel very warm-
(speakers laughing)
We need more of that.
We need more of them.
- This is their film, you
know, the two of them.
And for us to be able to support them
in these roles where we're really just
really amplifying their incredible talent.
They carry this movie
and we're so proud to be
a part of something that
shines a light on them and
all of the young people on the film.